the internet is full of people telling
you how to train and how not to so much
so in fact that training can often times
seem quite restricted and boring
it doesn't have to be as long as you're
moving you're improving and with that in
mind there are a billion and one
different ways to train should you stay
safe sure are there faster ways to get
to the top maybe but our ancestors
stayed strong and healthy without anyone
telling them how to move
if we listen to our bodies they'll tell
us what they need
as long as you're moving you're
improving so don't let anyone tell you
you're doing it wrong here are just some
of the things you don't have to do
you don't have to train in the gym
your body is gym enough better yet why
not get outside where every fallen tree
can be a balance beam or a barbell where
every ditch is something to jump over
and every rock is something to throw
you don't have to squat or deadlift or
curl or push up or pull up there are
countless different alternatives for
every movement instead of forcing
yourself into doing what you think you
should be doing do what feels good
you don't have to lift weights or run or
do any kind of training that doesn't
speak to you once again there are plenty
more options whether you prefer rock
climbing calisthenics swimming dancing
sports or some combination of the above
[Music]
you don't have to stick to one
discipline specialization can be dull it
can lead to imbalance find the perfect
mix for you
you don't have to follow a program
each workout can be unique and offer its
own challenges as long as you
occasionally return to similar movement
patterns you'll see compound gains if
you don't you'll gain in entirely
different less visible ways
you don't have to lift more than your
friend or that person on instagram
there's no pressure it's not a
competition to go at your own pace
[Music]
you don't need to use perfect form or
full range of motion
there are actually benefits to using
partials and short ranges of motion and
there is no such thing as a bad exercise
you can try to never round your back
when picking up weight but that sure
isn't how you move in the real world and
while there is such thing as poor form
that can lead to injury this is mostly
only an issue for those moving very
heavy weights or doing huge sets doing a
push-up slightly wrong isn't going to
end your fitness career no one taught
you how to walk but chances are you're
doing that just fine
try and improve but don't critique
yourself to the point of not having any
fun at all this isn't school
you don't have to train heavy or hard at
all don't feel like pushing yourself to
your limit that doesn't mean you can't
train lifting light weights going for a
light run is all still beneficial you
don't always need to destroy yourself in
fact you never do
you don't have to track your progress
tracking your numbers can be a useful
metric for progression they don't tell
the whole story and you should never be
a slave to them
if you're regularly putting in a decent
effort you will improve trust in the
process
you don't have to progress
that said you also don't have to improve
if you're in okay shape and you're
enjoying what you're doing if you're not
getting any worse well then you're doing
okay if your training is invigorating
and if it helps to fight the forces of
entropy then it's more than worthwhile
but even without trying you'll be
gaining new skills and building
resilience because if you're moving
you're improving
[Music]
[Music]
i hope you enjoyed that one guys just a
short little motivational speech
something a little bit different
of course i believe it's important to
avoid injury and avoid movements that
can cause injury but don't get so
wrapped up in this that you don't have
any fun with your training just get
outside have fun and move experiment and
come up with new ideas it should be fun
and if it is you'll find you're much
more likely to stick to it what do you
guys think anyways let me know in the
comments if this resonated with you at
all
if you like the idea of training in a
way that's more excitable and
adventurous then you might enjoy my
ebook and training program super
functional training there's a discount
on that right now and you can find a
link in the description down below but
either way thank you so much for
watching this one and i'll see you next
time guys bye for now